[SOUND EFFECTS PLAYING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Welcome to Vietnam.
Here, bear bile--
the digestive fluid
stored in a bear's gallbladder--
is being illegally extracted
from thousands of bears for
its supposed herbal medicinal
benefits.
Because of demand, this is how
thousands of bears in Vietnam
are being kept.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
WOMAN: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: All right.
So we're basically
going undercover here.
We're not going to use the
big camera because we're going
to try and buy the bear bile.
So this is Johnny.
Kiran is an American doctor who
has been here for surgeries.
And we're going to
see if we can pick up
bear bile from over here
with Johnny, our guide.
So we check.
[CAR HONKING]
JOHNNY: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
WOMAN: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
JOHNNY: $3.
ADRIAN BASCHUK: My God.
JOHNNY: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
WOMAN: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
JOHNNY: Yeah.
You can drink with a vodka.
ADRIAN BASCHUK: Yeah?
JOHNNY: Do you know this works
for men just like Viagara.
ADRIAN BASCHUK: Really?
JOHNNY: They drink it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: So
medically speaking,
is bear bile effective?
DR. KIRAN CHEKKA:
There's no studies
that suggest bear bile is useful
as a medication of any sort.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: So this is An.
An, say "hi."
AN: Hi.
ADRIAN BASCHUK: And she's the
new bear program coordinator.
We're headed to [INAUDIBLE],
which is about 45 minutes west
of Hanoi, and we're going to
see the actual bear enclosures
where bears are
caged and they're
being farmed for their bile.
It's out in the open.
You can see it.
We're going to pose as tourists.
Right?
AN: Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: So we're
now in [INAUDIBLE].
You can see it's more rural.
So here's our first
signs of bear places.
Damn.
I mean, this is just
open advertisement of it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: It's one street.
It's about a mile long, and it's
lined with bear bile places.
Oh.
There were-- those
are bear cages.
Yeah.
Those were cages of bears.
I mean, there were six or
seven of them lined up.
So stop.
Stop.
[CAR HONKING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: This place
is the most obvious place.
I can't believe that the sign is
just there, and it's like this.
WOMAN: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[DOG BARKING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: Oh, look at him.
So pretty.
[DOG BARKING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK:
Just one picture?
You guys want one picture?
WOMAN: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: One?
No?
WOMAN: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[DOG BARKING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: OK.
WOMAN: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: I just-- OK.
OK.
We go.
But she literally had--
how many bears were there?
AN: I think it's eight?
Seven to eight bears.
Very big.
ADRIAN BASCHUK: Huge bears.
I mean, the one was standing.
He was seven-- he must
have been seven feet tall.
AN: Yeah.
Almost two meters.
ADRIAN BASCHUK:
And the cages, they
were like-- there was
maybe a room of room
on each side for the
cages, and that was it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: So
let's stop here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: So
this one is allowing us
to take pictures of the bears.
Here they are in the cages.
Hi.
So pretty.
So there's one, two, three,
four, five right there.
And then does she sell anything?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK:
So we're literally
going to buy the bile now.
[DOG BARKING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: Ah.
OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: 20, 40, 50.
OK.
Do they know which
one this is from?
WOMAN: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: This
bear bile is from him.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: OK.
Literally.
OK.
All right.
That's OK.
So that was crazy.
I mean, I actually feel
tremendously guilty that I
bought this from there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: So you
estimate that over 2,000 bears
are in captivity right now?
PHU TAO: Yeah.
ADRIAN BASCHUK: Hmm.
So you can keep a
bear in a cage as long
as it's chipped for the
government to track?
PHU TAO: Yeah.
ADRIAN BASCHUK: But you
can't extract any bile.
PHU TAO: That's right.
That's right.
ADRIAN BASCHUK:
But it's illegal.
PHU TAO: I don't
know why people still
believe in using
wildlife products
as medicine and for--
especially for bear bile.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BEARS CRYING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK:
It's tough to watch.
Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK: So
this is the first bear
that we're seeing here.
I mean, how long was he kept?
DR. TUAN BENDIXEN: Seven,
eight years in links.
ADRIAN BASCHUK: Seven or
eight years in enclosure.
Now, here he is.
I mean--
DR. TUAN BENDIXEN:
Well, seven, eight years
in a cage, what
you've seen earlier.
You know, something
similar to that.
I mean, this one bear here,
you can see that it's disabled.
ADRIAN BASCHUK: Yeah.
Was it-- did it have
to be amputated,
or he came like that?
DR. TUAN BENDIXEN:
Normally-- the trap normally
either badly damage the paw.
About 25% of our bears
here or more came
in with either missing
limbs or missing paws.
DR. JOOST PHILIPPA: We have seen
cases where the gallbladder is
severely affected or the
tissues around the gallbladder.
Some of the animals have back
problems or joint problems
from living in a confined space
for a longer period of time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DR. TUAN BENDIXEN: I
think like the bears,
they can be very forgiving,
even though human
did this really bad
thing to them, you know,
cruel thing to them.
But at the end of the day,
they still tend to forget.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: On another
episode of Seeker Stories,
we explore a Las
Vegas underworld.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAN: People get so
comfortable living down here
with their couch
and their milk crate
and their clothes hung up, and
I think sometimes they almost
forget that they're
living in a flood channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: This episode is
a part of Seeker Stories.
To see all the stories we post
here, be sure to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]